il a dit iceberg
- Berg qu'est-ce que tu as qu'est-ce que tu as d'
accord promets que nous serons là d'accord merci
giggity de prendre le chant si tu
dis n'importe quoi
c'est horrible de travailler
tu viens de me donner une bague mère
autour de l'entrepôt continue d'avancer continue
avancer les gars
jonesing undershorts je suis désolé
shorts Jones et bonjour bien merci
et ensuite je saute sur votre
maison de pont Navajo merci
oh attendez désolé
je ne pense pas que vous vouliez une vie de crime
hey commercialisons des secondes vous ne pouviez pas
attendez dix secondes certains de ces drôles
nous n'avons aucune idée de qui vous parlez
Je suis l'agent fédéral Sarah Ashburn et j'ai
attrapé la tueuse des chutes rouges Mme.  M Je suis
sûr que vous êtes un joli pantalon chaud assez accompli
d'ailleurs vous voudrez peut-être penser
à vous raser au-dessus du genou la prochaine
fois lui donnerez-vous des conseils de beauté
possédez-vous un miroir
vous ne sauriez pas comment trouver la marque et
si  utiliser juste au-dessus de vous, vous ne savez pas
ouais je suis un bon gars d'accord je suis un
bon gars
25 ans dans la DEA j'ai
beaucoup plus de bustes à mon actif que vous n'en avez